let's talk about what Rhonda Santos is
doing and one of the things that I would
really really support him over and this
is from The Washington Post DeSantis
invokes MLK as he proposes stop woke act
against critical race Theory I'm a fan
they say
is Florida Governor Ron DeSantis was
introducing proposed legislation that
would allow parents to sue schools
teaching critical race theory in the
classroom he invoked the words of
Reverend Martin Luther King Jr that's Dr
Martin Luther King Jr to try and make
his point about the stop woke Act and
the escalating conflict over the
teaching of race you see how they do
that to drink race yeah okay nice try
quote you think about what MLK stood for
he said he didn't want people judged on
the color of their skin but on the
content of their character de Santa said
you listen to some of these people
nowadays they don't talk about that so I
tell you this the one thing I always ask
my liberal friends I say something very
very simply simple to them I say uh do
you support the message of Dr King
yes yeah oh of course absolutely and
then I'll say what about segregating
these classrooms on the basis of race is
in line with judging people on the
content of their character not the color
of their skin yeah and it for a lot of
people there's a cognitive dissonance
they get angry because they're very
tribalist slow because it's not fair
it's like the instant reaction well they
say they say colorblind Society is wrong
and I'm like so you don't agree with
with Dr King what Rhonda Santos is doing
is what I wanted I wanted Trump to be
doing the the left establishment lies
about what critical race theory is to
try and inject this into our society Joe
Biden gets rid of Trump's you know
executive order bans on critical race
Theory training and the leftists who are
in many ways populists many of them
aren't support this because this is a
precursor to a form of Communism or or a
path towards class instruction you can
bring that about yes
I think if MLK was alive today this
might be a little bit hyperbolic but I
think he would be villainized and
slandered by the corporate media I think
he would be Shadow band on big Tech
social media what's this phrase so I
will put quotes around it but but he
would be called by liberals Uncle Tom
or a white supremacist or well we have
seen people who use his words literally
be called that but look at look at how
they treat any member of a group whether
you are a woman like myself well I can't
they're yes all woman until it comes to
a woman like me right or they are
um for minorities unless you happen to
be Ben Carson or Alan West or Connor
Candace Owens or you know therefore the
lgbtq people unless you're Dave Rubin
was like it's everything has like a stop
point for them because it is it is the
ideology and the agenda was MLK
anti-lgbtq I'm not sure about I was
reading something I'm not entirely sure
the FBI had a lot of dirt on him showing
that he had extramarital Affairs that
they were using against him they
literally sent evidence of that to his
wife when he was in prison as the FBI
was sending MLK letters telling him to
kill himself in prison as they were
extorting him politically with these
larger bigger truths that they got on
him after spying on him he was a part of
the church and he was preaching that
kind of church lifestyle he was a
reverend
um I love how like if you believe in the
biblical definition of marriage like I
myself believe that now that's just like
dubbed anti-gay yeah and and he did have
extramarital Affairs and because of that
the FBI that was spying on him got that
information and was literally trying to
use it so he would kill himself that's
the that's the history of the FBI the
institution that now has all of
Epstein's secret files and videotapes
and and uh I was totally taught
conspiracy theories okay so I think
that's not true I think that's not true
I want to make sure yeah I don't but he
was a member of the church and he he
preached a lot in church and he was also
let's let's be fair he was also attacked
by the corporate media back then
um he wasn't seen as someone who is
extremely popular only after he died was
he was he seen as someone who was
popular and then kind of became more
popular by the day well that's typically
most leaders right and I think that from
a Evangelical background like I think
the beauty of actual history and the
beauty of religious history is that it
shows the innate sin that we're all born
into now nobody is perfect and so it's
it's actually I was homeschooled all 12
years I'm now a homeschool mom to an
eight four and two-year-old and uh it's
fascinating to me that right around the
time the CRT stuff started coming up I
was reading about like turn of the
century post-civil War like
post-oppression era pre-civil Rights
Movement
um Americans with my now eight-year-old
like Roll of Thunder Hear My Cry is her
favorite book and I'm like this is stuff
that I learned like I learned real
American history The Good the Bad and
the Ugly you know who hasn't been
learning it for the last 30 years kids
in public schools why are they not
learning it because of lazy teachers
unions that I could go after and so it's
fascinating to me that people just have
this thing where they assume that
everyone is supposed to be perfect and I
think really the problem boils down to
politically culturally pop culturally
whatever people just put people on a
pedestal that should not be there I
think this issue is is a very it's it's
right for Ron DeSantis to tackle it this
way Donald Trump did the critical race
Theory ban but they didn't they didn't
call it that they used very specific
language and what's fascinating When
Donald Trump issued the executive order
Banning these trainings he was following
existing law the 1964 Civil Rights Act
says you cannot discriminate on the
basis of race as one of its you know one
of its many titles and what was
happening at these these government
contractors was they were having
whiteness tray like anti-whiteness
trainings and there was one I think it
was the nuclear laboratory not which one
uh we're not sure super duper important
by the way like when you're working
around nukes so this is Christopher on
the atomic scale race race matters right
and they they made the white men go to
like some Retreat to learn about like
you you can't do that that violates the
law so Trump comes out and says hey guys
this breaks the law don't do it Joe
Biden comes in says come on man break
the law and and he just undoes the
executive order and I'm like this is
insanity so Ron DeSantis is stepping up
with this we'll see what you know if if
he does end up running it's tough to say
I mean if if Trump ends up running do
you think DeSantis would actually run
against them I do you do I do I would
support the Santa's over Trump I think
it's the census's only chance if he
doesn't run that's that's going to be
the the you know where a lot of people
aren't going to be following him and
supporting him after that because this
is his only chance really and honestly
like Trump can only sorry like uh Trump
can only blame like the state so much
for the early covet policy that he
implemented right so anybody any
Republican or independent or even
Democrat who runs against him can
literally look at all of the edicts that
he had two weeks to solve the spread
yeah
would be standing next to Donald Trump
on a debate stage and he would say you
know with all due respect Mr President
for the good work you did I would have
fired fauci on day one exactly and
everyone's gonna go yeah and that's true
any Republican that runs against Trump
that's all they have to say is why did
you keep fauci in you were knocking him
but you had the authority to get rid of
him why didn't you do that he wouldn't
do it I think it was was it Kushner I
think yeah I can't remember who we were
talking to they were like he was advised
not to do it really yeah he was advised
to keep him around he's too popular you
got to keep him there was a trump
Horsemen of the White House that Peter
Navarro was telling us I don't know if
this was on the after segment or during
the the the time that he was on but he
talked about it four individuals that
were telling him to keep fauci there and
that it would be better for Trump to
have to keep him what a mistake well we
got to see what Rhonda sand is willing
to do in in other areas awokeness is not
a reason for me to solely support
somebody yeah but I will say or mandates
or yeah but but I I gotta admit when it
comes to covid I would love I remember
back when I was telling you about 2019
it was so fast it was so great man do
you guys remember what life was like
before the start of the pandemic it was
amazing I could actually go speak on
college campuses and have real life
protesters
flying all over the world just checking
out crazy Florida is still like that
yeah Florida is normal yeah Texas for
the most part is as well by the way my
time in DC surprisingly I've not uh I
put on a mask in an Uber once and only
because the driver asked me and I
respect that when they ask I don't even
know what my rating is because I just
get into Ubers all the time on mass
um less masking in DC than La what's the
um what's the uh the courtesy with masks
and Uber do you get an unmasked and only
mask up if they ask or do you get in
with the mask I lie I tell a little lie
when I it's like do you have a mask I'm
like well I have a mask but I'm not
wearing a mask because you have to check
that button before you can order it
literally have you you uh you have to
wear three masks and then when you get
in you can ask the driver how many are
allowed to take off and if he tells you
to wear it may I just robe sir okay
I am very glad I don't know who here is
in relationships or not but like I've
been married for 12 years and I'm so
grateful that I like found my husband
got married young because like I could
not date today but then I talked to
friends or like reads random like
threads and stuff online about people
that date there was this one girl she
was like yeah we were having like
something training at the bar where I
work and this guy like had he was tall
he was fit you know had a good voice
asked me out and then they went out
after work and where they could take off
their masks oh no and she was like he
was better with the mask oh no yeah take
a look at this take a look at this video
oh yeah this video went viable
so it's clear that this guy's wife for
saying to another wants to wear they're
wearing these big plastic tubes but
they're holding hands they're like dogs
and what is the purpose like after a dog
gets you know what that's what he is
okay so I just gotta explain to people
people who can't see it who are just
listening there is a woman and a man
this is a report I think it's from RT
and the woman is happy she's showing off
that she's wearing a dog cone it's
effectively duck owned but the guy's
face is just he's like he's literally
yeah
that's like a live shot of me anytime
Gavin Newsom says that he's extending
the mask you know I'm like this guy man
I'm just like bro by the way she's way
too pretty for him yes and he knows it
and he knows and that's why he's doing
it look at she's watch this she does
like she she's twirling
Cinderella and then it shows look at
that taking pictures and then look at
the guy's face he's just she's not too
pretty miserable she's too crazy for him
that's what they call a smile when
you're not happy yeah
I think this is in Europe but I just
want to tell this man my friend
Florida yeah it's a real place he'll be
like no don't so is it true Florida's
not real last year when I left the show
the first day I got into Florida they
had a mask burning at the beach and huge
parties down in Fort Lauderdale and I I
went down there and I literally didn't
even unpack my RV I was like I need to
see this I need to see what's going on
here huge parties huge clubs huge bars
everyone's partying and there's like
hundreds of people on the beach and
they're all just taking their masks
literally burning them on fire being
like we're not gonna comply with this
absolutely nothing you can't do that in
California because then you're like
contributing to the bad environment
right so I feel like telling that guy
like some people have low T because of
age you have low tea because of that
thing that you're right yeah so I I
wanted to I'll bring it back to uh
Rhonda santis and that that humor is
exactly why I'm like that to me is is
leadership we also have to like he has
been under Fire for a year and a half
now almost two years I cannot believe
this but like in March we will be at the
two year mark from when all this
craziness began and he has been
consistent he has not count out he has
not given up they haven't found anything
on him as much as they have tried and I
think that he has handled it really
brilliantly
I'm a fan well the corporate media said
that he was going to going to be the
Butcher of Florida that there's going to
be a bloodbath that bodies were going to
be piling on top of bodies
though that was because it was because
of his you know uh elderly home policy
but the the amount of criticism that he
was able to withstand from the national
media attacking him is not noteworthy
and
um it's really going to be interesting
to see him tee off against Trump which I
think is going to happen no one else run
Bucky they're going to fight each other
they got a WWE it up the two of them
together should coordinate no matter who
wins and make it the biggest spectacle
on Earth just a Florida the hot Florida
action non-stop ego's gonna tell us that
sounds like a spring break
otherwise the corporate media is going
to overtake them and pump their
candidate and put Hillary in I mean they
have to work together otherwise but
here's the beauty though of New Media
like here's the beauty of what you guys
do like like the beauty of my phone that
I can go to and and people have the
ability like it isn't just the two fours
and sevens anymore right it's not the
three channels where you get all of your
information that my parents or my
grandparents thought were we had three
five and eight yeah we had two we had
two five nine it was 32. it's like four
four it was always Fox seven was always
ABC okay
ABC for us in Chicago two was CBS five
was NBC nine was WGN and
WGN yeah WGN Fox 32. thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time